[Music]
hello you're playing the waiting game
the show that helps you decide discover
and enjoy other things besides the games
that you would kill your very best
friend and step over your own mother
just to get your hands on early one
reader Julian Jade jewels worth rights I
said I like to celebrate the games as
much as the next guy you should do an
episode on half-life 3 in the event that
the show gets canned I make a cool 50k a
year and buy roughly one game per month
so these things are important that's a
great question JJ can I call you JJ
listen JJ you seem like a cool guy in
his early 20s in the unlikely event that
this is the final episode of the waiting
game here's all the things that you
should do while we wait for half-life 3
to arrive and probably never know
waiting for you Gordon but first some
backstory half-life 3 is like the holy
grail of games and I mean that in a more
literal sense than your average Troy or
Steve throws around the phrase Holy
Grail nobody knows if it is or ever was
real if a savior ever really held it or
exactly how crunk you can get using it
what we do know is that the half-life
series created by valve software is a
first-person sci-fi shooter with an
insane following is regarded by most to
be one of the greatest game series ever
made and half-life 3 is probably the
most anticipated game in the world so
you should definitely go and play Duke
Nukem Forever
even assuming gabe newell took to the
roof of the valve building tomorrow and
bellowed naked that halflife3 and Santa
Claus is real it would only be a mere
six and a half years since half-life 2
episode 2 came out Duke Nukem Forever on
the other hand was first announced in
April 1997 by 3d realms and only made it
into stores a cool 15 years later and
what's worse is it wasn't even that good
it was rehashed across several console
generations so by the time it arrived it
was already dated it was childish vulgar
and easy kind of like Greg really Greg
nothing right yeah there's heaps of
titles that required a long wait between
iterations that will definitely sate
your thirst for Zen killing the classic
tale Bambi was released all the way back
in 1942 look at his little feet well
fans of that film didn't see Bambi -
Bambi harder hit the silver screen until
2006
that's a 63 year wait Bambi along with
most of the original audience definitely
dead just right for finding your own
quiet space I'm not even recommending it
it's a cartoon about a talking deer and
rabbit then again deer and rabbit can be
hunted for game and half-life is a game
so by that virtue my show Greg you're
here to push the buttons fine you should
also play gunman chronicles this FPS
space Western started out as a
deathmatch mod moving across the quake
and quake to engines and finally
settling down with half-life where it
was commissioned into a full game it's
good and you should play it we have a
lot to get through and I have plans
aside from the fact that half-life 3 is
definitely being made there's always the
chance that it's not even though it
definitely is but just in case it isn't
you should check out Firefly
much like gunman Chronicles it's about
space cowboys it's made by Joss Whedon
and it's the best TV show in the world
frankly I don't even know why I'm
recommending this you should all have
seen this in fact if you've seen Gossip
Girl Glee or the hills and you haven't
seen Firefly head but a bag of hammers
and then watch it trade hell it's theft
this the best damn gun made by man it
has extreme sentimental value it's miles
more worthy in what you got what I got
she has a name so does this call it
Veera thing is due to the onset of
stupidity by morons Firefly was
cancelled after just 14 spectacular
episodes leaving regular people all
which led to please push forward which
caused which inspired
[Music]
which resulted in which brought about
the earthquake people eating and
shagging each other in the streets in
the fall of mankind but I digress
Firefly was the perfect example of
having your favorite toy taken away
smashed and then glued hastily back
together so you could play with it one
last time in the form of a feature film
called serenity it was nice to get some
closure but it's not what we wanted this
is what happens when you rush things the
opening scene of half life looks like
this soda is riding the London Docklands
Light Railway grab a lab coat and a
crowbar and take the route from Shadwell
to Becton it's like you're a real
theoretical physicist or try putting a
clock inside a microwave that way you
could create your own portal to Zen and
bring forth all right this about to step
in kids
don't actually put a clock in your
microwave it might actually kill you
break from the future so I just walked
from behind the camera that feels like
real skin you should also watch War of
the Worlds because these three legged
things look like these three legged
things and Starship Troopers because the
combine advisor is basically the
horrible bastard brain bug don't worry
it's afraid it's afraid it's okay
everything we recommend here on the
waiting game costs money so here's a bit
of extra free advice for the true
sensation of waiting for half-life 3 try
sitting on your left hand during your
next bit of alone time much like
half-life 3 it will take ages but the
results will be excellent Oh God and on
that note in case you haven't already
figured it out this is the final episode
of the waiting game it has been a treat
and a pleasure recommending all sorts of
books
TV shows films and weird bizarre
experiences for the past few weeks
Steve s stealing Tain's ed of the show
cool show thanks Steve while Troy T
Truman asks what do wise men say another
great question from another great
contributor and I'm sure I speak for
Greg when I say that producing this show
has been hugely hugely rewarding future
Greg come up here and take a bow I'm not
gonna shut up I know I speak for Johnny
when I say producing this show has been
hugely hugely rewarding come and take a
bow Johnny thanks Johnny
just time for our lovely slider outro
shot Greg if you would there's plenty of
other great content over at GameSpot
comm and youtube.com forward slash
GameSpot you can find me on such shows
as GTA Diaries and top 5 Skyrim mods of
the week as well as plenty of GameSpot
and news update
Greg can you just slide that smoothly
please my hands are numb feels weird
right
[Music]
I got that